in merito al tema del tradimento
ti posso dire che io ho tradito tutte le
ragazze comunque sono stato nessuna
scusa non so dirti esattamente perché
non è una cosa che viene inserita cioè
un gene pezzo di me dice vado attenzione
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata prima di
iniziare però ad ascoltare i vostri
messaggi ea parlare con l'ospite
speciale di questa di questa giornata vi
devo fare un piccolo avvertimento se
avete il cuore debole passate a un altro
video riascoltate di quelle vecchie
perché perché il tema di questa puntata
è tradimenti per il tema di questa
puntata ho deciso di invitare qui
all'interno degli studios di questo
posto misterioso una persona che oltre a
essere una grande amica è stata forse
anche la più grande delusione della mia
vita a camilla ciao amici
sei una persona becera esco a iniziare
questo episodio alla per la prima volta
sappiate che i commenti anche per
garantire la privacy di persone che
hanno ci sono diciamo esposte merda
verranno tutti quanti camuffate quindi
sentiamo il messaggio di federica
[Risate]
genitori ha trovato suo padre
ora ha detto la mamma un trenino magari
a capodanno ma che mi sono sbagliato
auguri papà che no non si può vedere con
il mio amico ha fatto il barman in un
locale vicino a casa milan
e questo cane avrebbe scritto da uomini
che sono una donna una sera hanno
raccontato che uno dei loro clienti
abituali ora adatto giovane che stava
per sposare sparisce e quindi diciamo
leader sua moglie
l'unico a cercare e non avete lavorato
si trova alla fine è stato trovato in
bagno
chi non uno dei proprietari del locale
in atteggiamenti diciamo così che la
stavano poco spazio
il progetto cioè se siamo da volto pini
ma domande 20 stava raccogliendo
l'asciugamano che è accaduto sto facendo
il tampone parigi è per niente essere
allevato da poco una sorta di pump
d'este che si fa le tonsille da anni
l'antica tecnica fidanzato dirlo è
niente possiamo chiudere cara amica fai
questo come si chiama il doppio gioco
calcio anche ma anche car ma detto tra
noi
la domanda proposta
magari mai non tradisce suo sì se tu
dici si vuol dire che non hai mai
tradito
sono stata per otto mesi con il re da
sulla mini parla così cinge la vita di
ogni era stato a capo della sua ha
scoperto ogni cosmari toccata al posto
di casa perché i fatti non ha capito
niente il ragazzo fingeva di stare con
di tradirla per quale scopo
le quali sgombro a volta trattata con un
ragazzo avrebbe tirato di avere un
cugino i denti con celle e che hanno
diritto dalla sua stessa macchina scusa
era servita perché si macera con a mia
insaputa violentato un'altra zarate è la
trattura vende un centro per la pop
tu credi alla storia che lui abbia un
cugino o molti gote se capisci che c'è
un parametro è logico in questa storia
due cugini non possono essere uguali
forse ci deve essere la prende proprio
al cuore nome che io amo your dice a un
certo punto ci deve essere una selezione
naturale e quindi alcuna forza avevano
lanciato indietro la mia esperienza
racconta riguarda gli alimenti anno
quando amati tanto così tanto che quando
io adesso inizia una relazione tipo di
un penso sia perché ormai alla colla
tipo con la penultima ragazza vogliamo
messo le corna team immediato avete
scacco una donna che con un uomo come va
il mondo per me li ciclisti killer con
di software celle ricevono possono
venirci male aprire niente con nessuno
perché caro ma niente con nessuno ma ora
qualcosa stiamo aprendo
bronzi ora qui una volta subito diciamo
così un tradimento perché stavo da una
decina di vecchi con una ragazza e ha
scoperto che delicati va con il mio
migliore amico classica storia diciamo
poi io per veline per il colletto anche
dopo ho fatto sesso con tua madre venire
che migliora la caratteristica privo di
questo carnefice senz'altro la maturità
lo possiamo dire una persona
assolutamente poco rancorosa e adulta
adulti e una parola sola mano ma lei non
aveva mai visti
se non lo sapeva che la legge era
fidanzato assegnata tel mi disse
chiamate le tende d'asta ragazza ma
questo come un'altra
e io gli dissi che anch'io lasciamo
qualcuno la sta centrando la caposala
canto è stato quando damasco mi hanno
scoperto che il ragazzo con la mia e io
no com'è possibile
qua siamo passati dal quale sta facendo
il signore degli anelli lo diciamo e va
bene che tu vuoi fratelli non conoscete
le rispettive fidanzate e cosa cosa non
si fa per 5 minuti per 5 maria rosi di
questa è la pelle delle cave scoperto
avrebbe ancora tutta da una ragazza
compatto questa ragazza e diventano
utilizziamo le menti migliori amici e
neanche lo scavo a lui che lo giorico ha
finalmente come una vecchia questa
ragazza non solo con altro ragazzo ma
anche come un pari prostitute
ovvio dire che ci siamo realizzare io
questa ragazza ragazzo e anche noi
una ruspa di carabiniere amore era in
difficoltà
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questa puntata
io ti ringrazio che milla per aver
pianto insieme per averla richiamare per
aver pezzo perso insieme quel g
d'innocenza che forse ti porta via la
tua infanzia un'esperienza formante un
romanzo di formazione
noi naturalmente ci vediamo nel prossimo
video e vi mandiamo tutti quanti un
bacio ciao